we did not see playstation neo they did
show off Sony VR and they showed up a
bunch of really interesting games for
someone if you are let's talk about the
hardware first though at 399 for the
basic version there is a 499 version
which includes I guess the move
controllers the camera and then some
software with as well now what do you
think about that Peter in terms of price
point we knew the price already I did
you notice i pre-ordered it months ago
okay well then let her get about that
and I even thought it was October I i
guess it's news but i thought we knew
this all may be made already I'm pretty
sure we did so considering the price
point what did you think about the
software that they were showing uh-huh
well I don't want to steal the show by
mentioning the one big one go for it
blew me res needle 7 man yeah I I'm okay
the news that Jordan Mara was working on
that game the guy used to work Konami
was involved with PT 2 degree it makes
perfect sense that that game has such PT
vibes yes it looks freaking incredible I
will be terrified to play that in VR
right I just thoroughly blown away not
only by what I was seeing but the fact
that Capcom is making that game mmm that
Capcom has taken a series and turned and
pivoted it so hard and not only that
it's like PT has been brought back from
the dead as resident evil yeah silent
Hills and has become resident evil like
how the hell does that happen so crazy I
mean obviously the story the teams are
probably different but this is the same
Ian if you're not getting pt5 vibes from
this we play different games right hi
this is coming a playstation 4
PlayStation exclusive also fully
playable from start to finish and
PlayStation VR what do you think about
that Alexa um so I can't really handle
jump-scare I did the whole time I'm
sitting there like this but I want it
but I always go for stuff like this even
though it scares me I am totally in like
this looks like classic resident evil
and that's what that series freaking
needs hmm it's it you know in a weird
way it's like the opposite of Resident
Evil's come perfect used to be so fixed
and edited idea look everyone but it's
that same sort of enclosed you know
super you know what's around the next
corner scary kind of thing God crazy
resonable 7 I mean the yeah Capcom spend
the difference between Microsoft and
Sony but you got to say someone he's
probably got in the
better attitude is my dream yes and can
I just say Osaka coffee shop with my god
Surrey with those hops image it was
totally a thing but this completely took
me by surprise also the throwback to the
biohazard name Yeah right was
interesting because you know that's
that's what resident evil is called in
Japan it's called biohazard so do you
think that's what they're calling it
resident evil 7 biohazard i think i read
a press release i came out after this
was shown in japanese and it said like
resident evil like and the evil was like
with the VA right with the roman
numerals and i had biohazard as well so
that's what they're calling it over the
thing Wow I am super excited like when
this trailer was playing I I was like is
this no this comfy like resident evil is
not a first person like right right like
I'm curious to see how it'll be played
when you're not in Vegas absolutely
matters how it's going to tie into the
the world of resident evil yeah
absolutely like we don't know anything
about the character or like who this
year's that you're playing or where like
Silent Hill has done the you know inside
of one half thing before as well as PT
but yeah it's yeah how big is this right
that's the cuts another question yeah
and is it just a one place or much level
so many questions
Oh